Cristiano Ronaldo and it's fun to kitsch
and took it hits that long
[Applause]
[Music]
hey this is Oscar day as filling him for
freelancer Richard way Klingon his PES
2019 review PES 2019 feels like the
beginning of an exciting new era for
konami x' long-running football series
visuals have recieved a much-needed
overall and the on pitch action has been
tightened up refined and improved the
series lack of impactful licenses and
insipid UI and commentary at issues that
persist but PES 2019 builds on what was
already a runaway title winner to set a
new high bar for the series PES still
adopts the same methodical pace tangible
sense of weight and breadth of passing
as it did last year but after a couple
of matches you begin to notice subtle
changes that gradually add up passing
for example has been improved with a
bunch of new animations bringing each
kick of the ball to life with startling
accuracy players are intelligent enough
to contextually know what pass to play
and when giving you a greater sense of
control over each passing move the
fluidity of players movement and the
responsiveness behind each button press
leader moments of scintillating football
whether you're patiently building from
the back carving a team open with a
clinical counter-attack or who f---ing
it up to your big target man ball
physics have been reworked and greatly
contribute to this to making that little
white sphere feel considerably more like
a separate entity than ever before
there's an authentic flow and
unpredictability to the way the ball
moves curling and dipping through the
air spinning off a goalkeepers
fingertips and neatly coming under your
control there's also more physicality to
matches in PES 2019 with players
realistically jostling for position and
barging each other off the ball there
are few better feelings in PES than
leaving a defender for dead with an
eye-opening piece of skill and this
feeds into an added emphasis on player
individuality cut inside with Leo Messi
and he's liable to flick the ball over
the outstretched leg of a defender using
his low center of gravity to peel past
them before rasping a left-footed shot
into the bottom corner
Paul Pogba will saunter on the midfield
finding pockets of space and using his
large frame to maintain possession and
Cristiano Ronaldo were hanging the air
on crosses for what feels like an
eternity it's not all roses however as
it does still share some of the more
disappointing aspects of its
predecessors referees for example a
maddeningly inconsistent both too
lenient and too harsh in the same match
one match presentation is bland and
lifeless a new naturalistic lighting
engine produces some stunning sights but
the UI surrounding it still feels
trapped in the past and still walk
commentators Peter Dorian Jim Begley
returned with the same disjointed
dialogue we've come to know and hate and
pace is still trailing FIFA when it
comes to official licensing but the loss
of the Champions League and Europa
League licenses to EA a case in point
Konami has responded by obtaining more
licensed leagues than ever before but
these aren't the standout leagues that
are gonna move the needle in the same
way the premiere legal illegal would
thankfully the PES community does an
amazing job creating update files if you
want to modern the team's players and
kits that are missing this is only
possible on ps4 and PC disappointingly
MRSA League remains almost untouched the
International Champions Cup they've used
as a short preseason tournament and
transfer negotiations have been slightly
reworked giving you more flexibility
when it comes to player fees and
contracts at least goalkeepers have
finally seen some enhancements they're
essentially useless when rushing off the
goal line regularly failings closed down
and attacking players angles but this is
where the faults end they've impressed
with a range of new animations that
banished their previously robotic nature
as they pull off some eye-catching
fingertip saves
you'll need your keeper to be in top
form on the later stages of a match to
the stamina system in PES 219 has been
reworked to play significantly more
importance on your players fitness this
visible fatigue feature means you can
run a team ragged to see them look
increasingly leggy as the match wears on
essentially opening up space for you to
exploit with fresh legs off the bench
this isn't a one-way street though as
you'll need to be mindful of your own
player stamina as well this forces you
to play a more considered game of
football sprinting only when it's
absolutely necessary and making timely
substitutions when the situation calls
for it this is a game-changing feature
and it wonderfully complements PES brand
of authentic methodical football PES
2009 teens online servers surprisingly
stable considering the series history of
troubled connections and my club
introduces a few changes to its ultimate
team ask formula feature players and I
release each week without standing
performances in the real world
translating to attribute boosts in PES
the way you obtain new players has
changed too with players bundled in
packs of four as opposed to the single
player you would get in previous
iterations ultimately these tweaks don't
alter the structure of my club too much
but it's a fun mode to engage with
purely to play more of PES h standing
round a fool for as long as EA continues
to develop FIFA and hold a monopoly over
official licences PES will always be the
scrappy underdog just hoping for a
surprise upset the lack of licenses for
top tier leagues remains a sticking
point but PES continues to make
brilliant strides on the pitch building
on what was already an incredibly
satisfying game of football to produce
one of the greatest playing football
games of all time
[Applause]
[Applause]